hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the last episode of the
hundred mario challenge because i'm
about to fail if you're wondering why
the level changed from the last one it's
because screw that level i only have
four lives left i have four lives and
i'm not happy I'm not happy I am an
unhappy camper
I am so unhappy you would not believe
how on happy I am about life and
everything in life and the life that I
love to live and the living the love of
the life that I have and all the life
love and the love of life that is
coursing through my love veins for life
and all of its wonderful life nice god
[ __ ] yo charging through the opening to
murder me well eat a dick because you
can I hope that all of your drew all
hello hello secret I'll take some of you
anymore anyone else want to be a part of
this part of this pity party hosted by
markiplier but now I got triple spray
that'll make it a little easier wish I
had gotten that from the beginning
because frankly I need all the help that
I can get oh oh
[ __ ] you all oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
everything about that oh god damn it oh
god damn it
Oh No hahahaha it's like a [ __ ]
homing beacon it's so [ __ ] I was
having it I had it in the pawn uhm and
don't [ __ ] lose it please god damn it
no golf let's go ah hey thank you thank
you thank you thank you yes yes Oh God
oh but I didn't get any bonus lives but
goddamn it why couldn't it have been
like that I'm in such pain okay two
lives left
can I make it with just two lives whoo
five levels in two lives you bet I can
I am broken inside in every way I am
broken
please tell me that these [ __ ] oh I
didn't I didn't even notice what they
were
okay I'm going for it [ __ ] you why that
was it does it that was it that was it
that's it just that's it huh huh oh my
God if it's so disappointing what is
that just the end of my foot to roll
over and give up because that [ __ ]
got a part of me [ __ ] that [ __ ] that oh
such [ __ ] I'm so mad from the last
episode goddamn it I'm so sweaty my hair
isn't dry
[ __ ] a bracer yeah hello everybody
welcome back to the hundred mario
challenge we haven't even started yet
because we haven't everybody be quiet
it's okay
it's nothing going wrong we're just
gonna we're gonna do it again I mean for
the first time we're gonna do it again
for the first time it's gonna be great
everyone's a happy camper especially me
[ __ ] you okay what is that what what is
all of these am I supposed to take this
do I need this first what did god dammit
I don't know what you want I don't know
what you want from me why am I in the
first level doing the stupid key finding
[ __ ] God are real really really
really really really really really
really you're gonna throw that [ __ ]
at me no okay everything's fine I think
it 100% okay you know why I love life
and life is love love is life life is
love life is all these things life is
living life is live
life is the hell didn't I find another
one before I got up here yeah okay
so we're back into normal fashion
there's two yeah there's two these
buggers there's another one this is
going swimmingly I'm actually doing
quite well thank you for asking I know
you didn't really ask but it's it's okay
I'm gonna assume that you did cuz I love
you I'm talking to myself
ground pound it's the technique that
people wanted me to know about and I got
all the keys so that's good I can open
that will [ __ ] this then I guess I'll
never get out of here [ __ ] that [ __ ] you
I mean thank you for letting me go
through there please lead me to the end
because I don't want to deal with this
anymore [ __ ] off you know [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you eat ten fireballs and then drown in
the river of magma oh why do I have to
do this again why must I torment myself
again why must I subject myself again uh
first clear I was the first clear of
that level and yet somehow it was ranked
as expert great that means that I'm an
[ __ ] I don't know what I'm doing
let's go for broke I like pals let's see
how this does me
and we're doing what exactly
I needed the spring maybe I could jump
off god dammit god dammit are you
kidding me oh [ __ ] ha ha ha ha
this gives gonna be choices and one of
them kills me one of them is what I need
that's that's the way this whole map is
gonna go isn't it the way this whole
douchey I can already tell it's douchey
because of what you're already putting
in front of my guide I know douche when
I see douche oh boy Wow yeah am I gonna
have to do it again oh good I bet the
POW this time because the POW didn't
work last time so what else would I do
with my little that would led to death
that's I was right but I was just too
early because who would have known that
a swamp would have been coming down the
chute ready to slam into my nubile body
no no not everything is awesome
everything is cool when you're part of
the team hurry is awesome live in our
dream don't please just let me live let
me live my life let me live my life with
all the mistakes that I've made but just
let me live that's all that I ask that's
all I ask
all right
haha [ __ ] you just heat eat dicks whoo
oh god here we go again
well Yoshi would be too simple
I bet it's this it's the spring it's
flour all right
let's see what happens probably not what
I needed well that doesn't seem
promising oh it was the spring yeah I
was a sprout [ __ ] off man goddamn it you
suck you suck like this game was
designed this level was designed to make
me angry just in random chance why don't
you why don't you play and everyone
loves random chance everyone loves going
into the brand new level with not
knowing what the hell they're doing
not letting skill be any part of it and
I don't have a lot of skill I'll be the
first to admit that I don't have tons of
skill but that don't matter when it
comes in the face of all the [ __ ] oh
yeah [ __ ] you buddy [ __ ] off with your
sad face no the spring was not what you
needed
it was the Oh sh cuz you kickoff for the
ocean you do that oh we blew your stupid
dinosaur
okay here we go
how's that not making it house good oh I
could have made that at any point wait
could I make that without losing Yosh
nah well alright well there we go then
I've made it I'd no no hi this one you
son of a [ __ ] no you ass bag
I love random chance it's full of dicks
and they're inside of me but not in a
good way
Hey I couldn't possibly have failed any
harder at every encounter that I have in
this certain endeavor that I've done
here and I guess this one's the winner
yes okay oh god no oh god no the p-block
I'm going to guess and be wrong oh come
on you are joking
Oh
oh not another one not another one
come on you have got to be joking
well yo she's as good as a spring I
guess probably needed the POW block they
don't even give you the common courtesy
of a way to kill yourself you have to
start over my jaw I don't want to do
this what do I get to the douchiest
levels do they follow me do they find me
this isn't fun this is not fun it's not
fun
you guys better appreciate what I've
done for you the sacrifices I've made no
not that van don't do that okay let's go
with the Yosh not jumping over it
oh oh oh please end it this is the end
there's nothing below me
well first I need to check if there's
anything below me and I guarantee
there's not nope
so there must be a way - there must be
something that I can do with a Yoshi on
the way back
maybe there's something oh hello
no but I could get I could have just
gotten the Yoshi whoa hello
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
the hell what is what is this Oh aah I
was supposed to get a spring there yeah
okay I got it I get it I get it I get it
I need to put a spring there ah okay all
right I got it okay I need to put a
spring there and that's gonna let me go
up higher there so I need the Yoshi to
be able to grab the spring this still
isn't fun I don't mistake my smiling for
fun it just means that I solved the
douchiness that was presented in front
of me okay so now we're gonna go back in
the return pipe we're gonna go over here
we're gonna do this we're gonna go back
in we're gonna grab the spring we're
gonna go up we're gonna go down we're
gonna have lots of fun wait thousand lie
we're not gonna have lots of fun okay so
how do I wait oh no oh wait I can just
do this yeah that'll do then that wasn't
the solution that wasn't the answer and
now I have no goddamn idea what it wants
me to do there's no way to get oh whoa
what the [ __ ] he hit a P block
apparently I'll take it if this is what
I have to do
nope I knew I knew I knew I knew the
second that I warped into this goddamn
level that it was gonna be nothing but
who made this Kevin
[ __ ] you Kevin [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you give one these big ol numbers for
you [ __ ] you okay let me just as a last
ditch I'm gonna find out what's in that
question with my life
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] thank you everybody so
much for watching I'm broken forever and
always irrecoverable so thanks again as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
I'm setting the tree thing is this
treated uh grow naturally a little bit
alright no time for that we gotta go Oh
sue